on reste dont l'économie band c'est une
start up high tech versaillaise elle
vient d'être stark sacré start up de
l'année 2016 face à 1600 autres ronds
concurrents une récompense décernée par
bonjour idée un magazine collaboratif
des start-up le jury était composé d'une
dizaine de milliers d'internautes mais
aussi d'experts de l'entrepreneuriat les
détails avec fanny bourdon et william l
connecter les 4 milliards de personnes
qui ont sont encore exclus à internet
c'est le challenge que s'est lancé
albert schumann en 2011
il a créé sa start up bibande cette
technologie s'appuie sur le réseau 2g
déjà existantes presque partout dans le
monde pour proposer une connexion
internet aux pays qui l'ont pas nous
sommes une start up qui a développé une
technologie qui a pour objectif de
réduire la fracture digitale mobiles en
permettant à tout possesseur de
smartphone de rester connecté à internet
quel que soit le réseau disponible de la
4g 3g jusqu'au sms
et quelle que soit sa qualité big band
c'est aujourd'hui trente salariés dans
trois pays différents
les etats unis l'algérie et la france en
pleine expansion le concours bonjour
idées leur a récemment décerné le prix
de la meilleure start-up de l'aller ça
va nous aider d'abord autant de
notoriété bien évidemment d'autant plus
qu'on est en processus de levée de fonds
comme toutes les start up c'est pas
notre première et qui est évident que
pour les investisseurs le fait d'être
lauréat c'est aussi un gage
supplémentaire de valorisation
d'entreprise des bornes est la deuxième
société à avoir intégrer la pépinière
d'entreprises de versailles en 2011 ils
reçoivent deux cent mille euros de la
cci pour lancer leurs prototypes
pourtant albert shulman avoue qu'entre
prendre aujourd'hui n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille
la difficulté c'est se demander comment
on va payer le salarié à la fin du mois
c'est d'obtenir les choses de
l'administration aussi rapidement qu'on
devrait les avoir même si ça a
énormément progressé
c'est bas les réponses dans les pays
émergents les réponses vont pas aussi
vite que chez nous non plus donc d'aller
pousser pour avoir les répondre tout ça
se mélange
la technologie qui devra marcher ont
fait une démonstration et justement ça
marche pas omar ont fait la
démonstration bref tous ces petits
moments qui peuplent la solitude de
l'entrepreneur mais qui en même temps
nous renforce parce que c'est comme un
parcours du combattant une espèce de
marathon de vitesse sur lequel non
seulement au foot du rhénan que ce fut
dur et avec une bonne vitesse pour être
capable de
distancé ses éventuels concurrents asie
du sud est afrique et moyen-orient le
marché de bebon ce sont les pays
émergents ils viennent de signer un
accord avec le gouvernement du
bangladesh
objectif offrir internet aux 145
millions de personnes dont le smartphone
ne se connecte pas